As many of you might remember in October I
had appendicitis and had surgery, uh, here
in Boston and I was out for a couple of shows.
One of the things that I've been telling you
is that once I have the total cost of my procedure,
I would sort of open the books so that we
could look together and uh, confirm once again
how absolutely and utterly insane our healthcare
system is. I now have those numbers and I'm
ready to show them to you and they are shocking,
truly. So, quick reminder. Last Monday I told
you about how my health insurance is changing
from 2019 to 2020 if I choose to stay on the
same plan right now, I pay four 21 a month.
That's $421 a month. Uh, that same plan goes
up to $458 a month for inferior coverage.
In 2020 my out-of-pocket maximum goes up.
My copays go up. Tons of people who are either
from other countries or have employer subsidized
insurance emailed me shocked that this is
how bad it is here in Massachusetts where
we're supposed to be better off than lots
of other places in Massachusetts. Now I am
ready to tell you the full cost of my procedure.
Now, I had looked up what does an appendectomy
cost in the United States and I found a range
that says it can go anywhere from $1,500 to
$180,000. Now. Presumably the high range of
that is if it's a more complex appendicitis
with a ruptured or perforated appendix where
you often have to stay in the hospital for
several days to treat the infections that
sometimes happen. Now, to be clear, I got
good care.
The surgeon was great, the anesthesiologist
was great, the nursing staff was great. Really,
you know, I don't recommend getting an appendicitis,
but it was a made as least bad as possible
by really great medical care that I received.
They don't control the prices. This is not
about them. My appendectomy costs $27,495
for the eight or so hours that I was in the
hospital. Let's put the numbers up so we'll
go through this particularly for people that
are listening. The anesthesiologist's fee
was about 1700 bucks. The surgeon charged
about 2,500 the ER visit to me at the emergency
room by a different surgeon to tell me about
the procedure was $460 the emergency room
doctor who came over and told me they think
I have appendicitis. That was six 82, of course
I had to pay a $368 or was a bill. This is
not what I had to pay.
The radiologists charged nearly $400 for looking
at my cat scan and telling me I have appendicitis.
I had the urgent care visit earlier in the
day where they told me, we don't think you
have appendicitis. That was wrong. That was
four 45, uh, my postop visit and blood work.
And then the big charge was the facility and
all of the different supplies, the operating
room, the anesthesia, et cetera. More than
$20,000 there. My pain pill killer, prescription
85 for a total bill of $27,495 for my, as
they call it, uncomplicated appendicitis.
So the next question is how much do I pay?
I told you I have a $2,000 annual deductible,
uh, for my health insurance. And I expected
since my healthcare spending was minimal and
I didn't think I had made any progress towards
the deductible being covered earlier in the
year, I expected I would have to pay $2,000
and I was right.
But in fact it is more. So for me, my out-of-pocket
on my nearly $28,000 appendectomy is my $2,000
deductible, a $55 urgent care copay from earlier
that day, a $50 copay for my post operational,
uh, blood work, a $30 a postop visit, copay,
a $300 emergency room copay. I also had to
pay 20 bucks out of the 85 for the painkiller
prescription, which I didn't even end up taking.
And then of course, I also paid for my insurance
in October four 21. So my total October, 2019
spending including my insurance premium for
this appendectomy, $2,876. Just a few interesting
items from my itemized bill. There's so much
more to it, but just a few things I've found
notable. Uh, when I arrived they said, Hey,
listen, we should just, we don't know what's
going on yet, but anytime people come in,
we try to keep them hydrated. So we're going
to give you an Ivy.
I said, sure. That was $188. Um, I, I'm glad
they did it. I mean, it does seem like a good
practice, but that nearly $200 for the Celine
bag. Um, a CT, the CT scan, of course, they
needed to do a CT scan to determine if I have
appendicitis. That was more than $2,000 billed
to insurance. The Ivy Tylenol I was given
before the procedure was $153. And you know,
they didn't leave me in the hallway. They
brought me to a recovery room after the procedure
that was $678. Now what's interesting about
that is they said that because they would
probably only keep me a few hours after the
procedure, they didn't need to bring me upstairs
to a room. Now, if I was brought upstairs
to a room, we would be talking about thousands
more dollars because that would be considered
being admitted to the hospital.
They didn't do that. Instead, they put me
in the recovery room for 90 minutes. That
was six 78 much cheaper than bringing me up
to a room. So once again, what's the big picture
here? The nurses were great, top-notch surgeon.
Anesthesiologist was great. Everyone's bedside
manner was great. They treated my girlfriend
really well. Uh, even after, as I was already
on Valium and being wheeled in, I yelled out,
I hope I don't die, which was not exactly
in confidence, inspiring to her at the time.
They treated her well, they treated me well,
but this is an insane system. Now I want to
be really clear, owing $2,800 it's not going
to bankrupt me. Right. I always assume that
at any time, because of the insurance I have
with the $2,000 deductible, I might owe two
to $3,000 at any time if I have a need for
medical services.
So it's not going to bankrupt me. But that
puts me in a privileged position because we
know that half the country, I believe it is,
can't afford an unexpected $400 bill. What
happens with a $2,800 bill? It's a sickening
and disgusting, uh, system. Nearly $28,000
and of course the hospital's not getting $28,000
because my insurance will go to them and say,
we're only paying this amount, and the hospital
accepts it. And the fact that they know they
only get part of it back from the insurance
causes them to have higher and higher sort
of MSRP book rates for a lot of these things.
If the system is broken, I don't pretend that
what I had is even close to the most serious
or expensive thing that people would have.
This is relatively simple, uncomplicated thing
and still look at what we're doing,
talking about sickening, disgusting system.
Hope this gives you some insight, particularly
to our viewers outside the U S as to how all
of this works.